um so black cat all right so black cat
for me
okay so you know how my character like
my my avatar on youtube
yeah oh so that came from black guy from
black oh my god oh sorry
kentaro who's the guy who made black cat
he has this thing in all of his manga so
he also illustrated to love her as well
yeah um
i mean it is [ __ ] good but um he has
this like kind of easter egg thing in
all of his manga where in every chapter
of his manga he puts this like little
white cat in at least one panel of every
chapter of his vlogger just as like a
little hidden easter egg and it's that
cat face that i use as my mask so like
originally like [ __ ] back way back
when on like new grounds and [ __ ] like
that that was just my logo oh and then
and then it adapted into my current
avatar but like i don't know black cat
was like
it's weird it's definitely heavy
nostalgia factor but i think this was
the first time i ever read a manga and i
was like wow like monger art is so
[ __ ] talented
it was the first time where i was
actually wowed by a piece of artwork do
you want to explain what happened to it
i can try and explain but i honestly
can't remember anything it's been a
while yeah it's been a while for me as
well yeah like you want to try this
he's not a black cat no but that's like
his code name yeah he's an assassin
right
he's an assassin yeah he's number 13.
that's it
his name is train he has two guns train
hardness two guns oh is that it yeah
train hardness train hard two guns two
guns yeah he has two guns two pistols
yeah and
the sven and eve i believe with the
names
i remember that this was the first
because i when i just got into anime i
don't see anything i remember about it
this is the first show that i was like
yeah you know what not every anime is
above a seven
this is the first show that i was like
i'm gonna teach you a lesson as an
example to the other anime five you know
what i mean like i gave it a lower score
than i would have just to be like yeah
you know what i'm thinking that's the
proof of a point i give out schools yeah
okay give it five because i didn't i
think i remember watching like a few
episodes of black cat years ago and it
was just me it was just that phase where
you'd watch everything yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then i was like cool guy in the
black coat he looks kind of cool i
watched a few episodes and it was just
like wow
so what happens extremely well
so
black cat is like he kind of uh so train
obviously he starts off as this like
assassin but then he escapes from the
organization that he's part of and he
basically the entire manga he gets
chased by the organization members
to come back to the organization because
he has like all the syrians or whatever
yeah and like there's a dude in the
organization or i think who also left
the organization who was like he's
basically like the quintessential male
yonder
like it's really like i remember the the
main bad guy is like i don't know i've
never really heard of like a male
yandere antagonist before in a manga
yeah especially in the show no matter i
just realized out of context you kind of
sound like you're describing john wick
or something it's like and he left the
organization and he isn't
an excessive
gold coin
[Music]
but yeah basically and then like sven is
the guy who like has like uh he's like
an explosives expert and then eve is
this uh he's like this she's like this
test tube like experimental this is when
every single manga had to have like a
ragtag band of
uh people who could do special things
yeah and have comedy okay so why is this
in your three by three i'm so curious
it's in my three by three because it was
one of the first manga okay so when i
was growing up reading manga i obviously
started off reading things like doraemon
and like you know the quarter quarter
comic magazine which is more aimed
towards kids under the age of 10 years
old right then when i got to around 10
11 years old i was like oh you know what
throw him on quarter quarter stuff
it's a bit too young for me i've got a
big pp now i'm a big i'm a big boy now
i'm i'm about to enter middle school
right i want to read some some of this
middle school
dance
so i was like you know i want to read
this like show name jump thing that i
keep hearing all my japanese friends
talk about yeah so at the time i
borrowed one of my friends shonen jump
magazines yeah and i think that
particular magazine black cat was on the
cover of it oh okay because black cat
had like because like every month and uh
every week on show and jump they have
changed yeah they changed the cover you
know some chapters have like you know
colored pages and some of them are like
have like center colors and stuff like
that and i think black cad had a front
color chapter
and yeah again like you know you go from
the rime onto this
right like clearly this is gonna make
you go whoa
what the [ __ ] is that
and so
yeah and i think like honestly
i really enjoyed it i mean kentaro i
think still makes some [ __ ] godly
character designs i mean you know the
reason why tolava was so [ __ ]
infamous is because like the character
designs
[ __ ] cute like he knows how to draw
really just aesthetic looking characters
and like you know black cat i feel was
definitely when he was still kind of in
his like younger times where like he
hadn't quite refined his art but near
the end of black cat his art just got
better and better and better and better
and like okay i don't know it's just
like a it's nothing like deep or
anything or like profoundly in any way
it's just a really solid manga right
okay um with like really just intricate
nice arts does it hold up today you know
what i haven't read it in quite a while
i did would you recommend it to someone
to read now oh it's hard
it's really hard
because like i don't know because i'm
obviously looking at this shirt because
this show is very
nostalgic
obviously looking at this with like
roasted glasses yeah yeah yeah so like i
don't know maybe if you're a fan of like
yubby kanter or stuff like if you liked
you know what you saw in tallahassee
okay and one like that with action
does it is the story does it kind of
wrap up is that a good conclusion yeah
it does actually it has a really nice
conclusion and like the the final fight
with like the male yandere antagonist
who is a really [ __ ] interesting
character and the powers and everything
like super cool yeah um yeah i don't
know it's again it's just like a really
solid shonen jump manga that's like very
inoffensive